hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm playing earlier than I thought I
was okay I am right in it right away so
we're playing here welcome to let's play
Asylum the interactive teaser now this
is a game that is pretty pretty
exceptionally high quality oh I see
Oh see this place was back in the day
yeah gobbling the stew rubbing it on
their faces
you can almost hear the sound of dishes
clanking huh okay so this game is an
interactive horror story and as you can
see it's not I can't I can't move with
the keys I am navigating hey listen you
can hear the things clanking in the
distance you can ah yeah that's cool
it's like a comedy stand all this dust
ah suck it up buddy
well not the dust but just suck it up in
general okay so I hear flies buzzing in
the distance hello disgusting good
conclusion Sherlock okay so we don't
have much here let me find out what this
is all about Tunnel of the Damned what
oh hi we are glad that you are playing
Asylum please note this is a work in
progress which is still rough around the
edges and may have some bug's take it as
a tutorial of sorts that does not
feature gameplay from the actual game
which is why we're not calling it a demo
we prefer to think of it as an
interactive teaser exploring a small
portion of the Hanwell mental institute
do get back to us with your thoughts and
feedback okay you can press the spacebar
to toggle indicators that show the
interactive spots around you
f 1 take a snapshot spread the whole
grandma control cycle through four
different camera speed um journal icon
okay so I would like a little bit faster
camera speed it's pretty slow
it's like fastest cameras B that's your
fastest okay that I guess that's a
little better but it just takes a little
bit to accelerate okay anyway so this is
actually really cool I like it it
there's a lot of detail in this place
something is blocking this door
something or someone or something if
it's a mosque hey around me it's
depressing uh-huh and dust lots of dust
oh stop whining about the dust hang on
what was the interactive F - oh whoops I
changes the gamma now let's go back to
gamma correction disabled F one knows a
snapshot what was the button for her
let's see I'll get through these in a
second - because there's some
interesting stuff here hey get back here
what the hell man mind her all right
click click oh space bar that was it
space bar so let's look at that because
it's gonna be hard - ooh that's handy I
was gonna click on button is for
you gonna press it it's alarm in a sense
that's comforting
that's comforting I probably just summon
the demons if there are demons in this
asylum which I'm assuming that this guy
is a former patient hello whatever
happened to this table must have been
nasty why I don't see any blood hurt
anything ever happened to this table
must have been nasty okay I get it
better leave the cafeteria quickly
unless I want more dirt in my lungs Wow
cry more about it you little baby okay
and there's some over here um oops
tripped
it's not working okay so that one
doesn't set off the cafeteria they were
used to play
soothing music during the meals soothing
for the bunch of crazies that you got
rolling around in the dirt with all the
dust too much grime most windows in the
building are protected in this manner
huh
still some in bees would tear and Hort
the grades and mash their heads on the
glass that's a little gruesome okay
what's over here looks like we got a
tree tree seems to affirm yep clap good
job everybody
high five if you all guessed that that
was a tree thousand points to Gryffindor
no way I can go around this tree really
you're not even gonna try cuz it seems
like there's some gaps here here you
climb around it here
crawl under it there all right this guy
doesn't want to get dirty like a freakin
germaphobe here probably what he was in
the institution for anything on that
board that I need apparently not I did
not see a blip so I will carry on my way
there is one singular blip and other are
many blips let's go over here
huh what's in that jar please please be
tuna please be tuna turn out looks like
dad's working not tuna damned if I know
which one okay the malfunctioning light
tubes are hurting my eyes where yeah
that seems to be a long long good okay
hello
Oh keys yeah best mattress you could
find on those iron beds and they still
wouldn't be comfortable that doesn't
seem logical when it was clean and
orderly a few years ago the infirmary
wasn't a cozy place right can't imagine
why not useless junk
this is junk the radiators aren't
working and it shows the cold here is
glacial ooh nice word it's very cold in
here apparently okay you could put the
best mattress you could fought those
radiators aren't working either uh-huh
I've lost hope good
just loads of useless you coat okay I
don't need to hear that against you
could find on those iron beds and they
still wouldn't be comfortable so cool ah
good thing I had those keys unlock that
so where does this lead besides the
dungeon ah going here
no thank you I don't want any I don't
want any at all is there anything here
let me spin in a circle real quick oh
this whoa wait a minute was this so what
are those airway leads to the basement
aha and second floor something tells me
I don't want to go to the basement
locked good but I wouldn't make it
through with so many things in the way
anyway
and I don't want to go to the basement
so it's a win-win okay I do not like
this place hey there are people still in
here transferred some inmates what are
you talking about this place is supposed
to be abandoned question mark I thought
this place was abandoned
apparently they've already transferred
so many things why are you here and why
is nobody else running the place answer
my questions what is going on here this
has got a weird just a little bit just a
little weird yeah okay so I don't see
any interactive points I gonna follow
the blue dots or else I'm just gonna be
lost why am I going in deeper I would
rather go out have beer at the bar or
something
anywhere but here oh I am NOT going in
the bathroom I'll tell you that okay
I'll go in the bathroom let's see what
we got
Oh is the crying coming from in here oh
oh that's heady bear
I wonder how many diseases in that
toilet yeah
probably all of them very clever sir oh
yeah get close get real close yes
somebody didn't like his teddy bear yeah
what's that down there ah oh don't do me
the surviving ah what up [ __ ] are you I
will kill you [ __ ] oh yeah you why am I
not more concerned about that water
whatever unspeakable fluid runs through
the pipes in this place I better leave
him alone he seems upset doesn't seem to
be anyone I'm not I don't see I'm not
moving worried through the pipes about
that little concerning to me who is this
guy that he just feels so normal just
like boom oh I better leave him alone oh
he's young he just misses what he or he
regrets what he did to his teddy bear
the condition of these patients it does
all the stuff to me man
so um yeah this is weird this is really
weird man okay I don't know how long
this what's in here hey hey back off
sonny jim that was weird that was pretty
weird but okay whatever they're just
silly patients what do I care
haha okay I'm going further into the
male lockup like I'm still confused as
to what's going on and why but I'm going
downstairs now
oh and that's it
okay Wow okay that is pretty cool I mean
really this looks great this looks
fantastic I mean out of all it's so
great to see an actual well made horror
game come and grace the horror genre
because you don't often see it and
something that takes something so
creative because I remember back in the
days when I used to play mist and Riven
and I loved exploring the islands and I
love the idea of just exploring this
horror feel it's like walking through a
haunted house in a way and it was just
that guy in the bathroom that was weird
it was we even weirder that the main
characters just so nonchalantly was like
yeah this happens but anyway yeah but it
did say in the journal what was this
tunnel of the damn thing what's that no
hit get back here get back here I want
to see what this was this tunnel the
damn thing cuz that lets go to the
so-called tunnel of the Damned okay one
of the most horrifying places in this
asylum hopefully I'll find the answers I
seek in there okay anyway so but this is
really cool I mean it's got so much
potential on everyone go to the website
support the project if you can because I
mean the music the atmosphere the sounds
just what was going on the place how
confused I was and how cool it is and I
mean it's cool that they throw in those
little bleep errs I mean you can turn
those off if you want to give it a
little more experimentation but an
honesty I wouldn't have known which
things to click on it all kind of
blurred into the environment but it's
very well detailed very well things
voice acting was good like all in all it
looks like it's gonna be a great game so
keep an eye out for it I will definitely
play it when it comes out you can play
this maybe I missed some stuff I went
through it pretty quickly so if I miss
some stuff you guys let me know link is
in the description it's a free download
to the teaser so thank you all so much
watching click the annotation before
videos it I've done and as always I will
see you
in the next video
knocks on door
Oh
you